merci d'être avec nous Stéphane rugini
pendant cette première demi-heure cette
sénateur la républicains des
Bouches-du-Rhône soutien de Bruno
Retailleau dans la campagne pour la
présidence des républicains et
rapporteur du texte sur le déroulement
des élections sénatoriales dont on va
parler en fin d'interview mais d'abord
un mot sur l'actualité on a vu dans le
journal Elisabeth borne géraldman
Olivier du soft hier on présentait les
grandes lignes du futur projet de loi
immigration ils ont répété en cœur qu'il
ne s'agissait pas d'un plan de
régularisation massive c'est l'une des
critiques des républicains est-ce que
vous êtes rassuré pas du tout quand on
analysera le texte mais il y a quand
même une incitation à la régularisation
de travailleurs
clandestins qui sont illégalement en
France et c'est un mauvais un mauvais
signal un mauvais message que nous
envoyons au monde au monde entier donc
effectivement vous savez moi je pense
que c'est un texte qui est
déséquilibré parce qu'il veut plaire à
la fois à la gauche et à la droite
et dans ce domaine là on peut pas faire
du en même temps comme dans tous les
domaines d'ailleurs et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on est très méfiant et
nous porterons je pense un message très
ferme au Sénat pour amender ce texte en
profondeur et passer un message de
fermeté en matière d'immigration vous
savez Bruno retaille le dit souvent mais
il faut avoir un message qui est
contraire à celui que présente le
gouvernement toute personne qui est
entrée illégalement sur notre territoire
français ne doit jamais être régularisé
c'est ce message là qu'il faut porter et
compromis vous semble possible sur le
texte
on parle de durcissement en même temps
des obligations de l'exécution des
obligations de quitter le territoire on
ne parle pas des laisser passer
consulaire comment faire pour peut-être
limiter les visas ou les aides au
développement si des pays ne jouent pas
le jeu sur les laisser passer
consulaires voilà il y a des absences il
y a des trous dans sur dans ce texte et
il n'est pas satisfaisant à l'heure
actuelle
aussi dans le journal sur les coupures
de courant alors Emmanuel Macron a voulu
rassurer les Français il fustige les
scénarios de la peur il vous aura
rassurer
de la peur c'est pas l'opposition qui
les a qui les a bâti c'est quand même
son gouvernement ou en tout cas les
autorités gouvernementales il faut
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
on est dans une situation assez
inquiétante dramatique parce qu'il y a
eu une erreur depuis 12 années sur la
stratégie de production d'énergie moi je
rappelle simplement qu'il y a 12 ans le
pays était exportateur d'électricité
aujourd'hui on en importe et ce n'est
pas lié à un contexte géopolitique à
l'Ukraine ou autre c'est typiquement lié
au fait qu'on a démantelé notre fleuron
nucléaire notre fleuron industriel qui
était le qui était le nucléaire et ça je
pense qu'on va malheureusement payer
cher cette
erreur de stratégie pendant des années à
parler de la campagne pour la
présidentielle je le disais vous
soutenez Bruno retaillod qui est arrivé
second du second tour mais il y aura un
second tour qu'elles le sont tirez-vous
de ce premier tour de scrutin je pense
que les militants ont envoyé un message
très clair au premier tour
plus de 58% on dit je veux du
renouvellement et en même temps je vais
une rupture c'est ça le message
renouvellement qu'incarner Aurélien
Pradier notamment renouvellement
générationnel et la rupture que Bruno
Retailleau réclame de ses vœux ça veut
dire quelque chose quand même ça veut
dire que pour le second tour j'ai vu
qu'Aurélien Pradier ne donnait pas de
concile de vote il essaie ses militant
choisir
écoutez je pense que vous avez moi je
suis dans une stratégie où personne
n'est propriétaire de ces voix donc on
peut toujours regretter de que qu'on
n'est pas appelé à voter pour un tel
lointel je pense que dans ce monde
moderne il est il est sage aussi de
prendre du recul bon il a fini troisième
il a fait une belle campagne il avait un
déficit de notoriété comme Bruno
Retailleau et ces deux personnes ont
fait une excellente campagne je vous
rappelle quand même qu'il y a quelques
semaines voire parfois quelques jours on
nous annonçait une victoire écrasante
d'Éric Ciotti il n'en est rien le jeu
est totalement ouvert Bruno continue
avec honnêteté avec conviction d'essayer
de convaincre les militants parce que
c'est d'abord et avant tout une élection
interne et ce que je peux regretter dans
cette campagne c'est qu'on n'est pas
suffisamment parlé de l'organisation du
parti plutôt débattre sur des lignes
politiques c'est très bien encore
faut-il être au pouvoir l'organisation
de partie je pense est essentielle et
Bruno Retailleau a une vision à ce
niveau-là on va parler et de la ligne
également comment vous pensez pouvoir
rallier les électeurs d'Aurélien Pradier
l'huile dans le Figaro ce matin il dit
ma responsabilité c'est d'endosser le
rôle de chef de la Droite populaire vous
lui reconnaissez ce rôle
le rôle de chef de la Droite populaire
enfin oui si le souhaite mais ça c'est
une c'est une formule sur la campagne en
elle-même
parle pas à la noix de populaire je
pense qu'on parle à tous les militants
dans une tente cas d'une campagne
interne et après on doit on devra parler
à tous les Français ce que
les militants d'Aurélien pradjer voulait
également une une rupture
générationnelle je pense que Bruno est
capable d'apporter sa vision sur
l'organisation du parti nous sommes en
phase en disant qu'il ne faut pas des le
premier semestre 2023 choisi le candidat
à l'élection présidentielle nous sommes
en face sur le fait que il faut un droit
d'inventaire sur nos années de
gouvernance pas sur la personne de
Nicolas Sarkozy mais sur ce qu'on a bien
fait sur ce qu'on a mal fait pour
retrouver une certaine forme de
crédibilité aux yeux des Français et
puis derrière je vous ai parlé de
l'organisation du parti cette vision de
rendre la parole aux militants de
déconcentrer en fait certaines certains
certaines décisions notamment pour le
choix des personnes dans le cadre des
investitures tout ça je pense
qu'Aurélien Pradier peut le partager ou
en tout cas des militants qui ont voté
Aurélien pragés
au premier tour pourront très vite
rejoindre brune retailleuse sur ses
positions là sur l'organisation dans un
entretien parisien Bruno Retailleau dit
que s'il était le président son premier
axe ce sera de faire un référendum
interne sur la ligne et sur la question
de l'alliance avec Emmanuel Macron c'est
vraiment ça la priorité oui c'est
vraiment ça la priorité ça évitera les
errements ou que certains peuvent avoir
en disant mais est-ce qu'il faut une une
coalition avec Emmanuel Macron dans le
parti pour vous il y a certaines
personnes qui s'interrogent dans le
parti ou chez nos militants je pense que
c'est important de rendre la parole aux
militants parle du référendum sur le en
fait ce qu'il faut ou pas une coalition
avec Emmanuel Macron la position Bruno
Retailleau est très claire la mienne
aussi je pense que on doit être ni
fongible dans le macronisme ni dans le
dans le pénis mais tout retrouver
c'est pas Marine Le Pen donc c'est pour
ça qu'on pose cette question là le
problème à l'heure actuelle c'est de
savoir comment on se positionne quand
les textes arrivent au Parlement est-ce
que on fait un gouvernement de coalition
je ne pense pas mais c'est aux militant
aussi de nous dire la ligne qu'ils
veulent qui veut emprunter mais au-delà
de cet aspect là des consultations
seront faites régulièrement notamment
sur les choix stratégiques vous savez
que pour Bruno retaillod on a 24 mois à
30 mois pour construire un nouveau
projet de société pour faire des
conventions thématiques sur 18 à 20
thèmes qui structure un projet de
société et je pense que c'est important
aussi que les militants puissent
trancher les différents choix
stratégiques par rapport à ces
thématiques au-delà des militants parce
que des conventions thématiques il y en
a eu des dizaines dans votre partie mais
il y en a eu des dizaines vous avez
raison et c'était les conventions
thématiques entre 2005 et 2007 il y en a
eu 18 et ça a donné le succès que tout
le monde connaît de de 2007 donc il faut
d'abord vous savez pour gagner une
élection présidentielle il faut d'abord
rassembler sa famille sur un projet de
société et cela ça fait longtemps on a
une forme de paresse intellectuelle
depuis de nombreuses années on l'a vu
dans le cadre du congrès 2021 on a
bricolé un programme un projet de
société en prenant des des propositions
de 2007 des propositions de 2012 de 2017
un essai d'aggloméré tout ça pour
présenter cela aux Français on a vu très
bien que les primaires à quatre mois des
échéances présidentielles étaient
mortifères pour notre parti puisqu'on ne
fabrique pas
un candidat à l'élection de la
présidence de la République en quelques
mois tout ça il faut tirer ces
enseignements là et se dire ben voilà
refaisons le modèle encore une fois qui
a fonctionné en 2007 c'est à dire
travaillons pendant deux ans sur notre
projet de société et après
interrogeons-nous sur celui ou celle qui
pourrait incarner le mieux ce projet de
société pour 2027 c'est juste une
question de calendrier de demain non
mais demain demain Laurent Wauquiez va
soutenir
erikiotti dans un meeting est-ce que
dans ces conditions il peut être si
Bruno retaille aux lampes il peut être
le candidat que vous soutiendrez à la
présidentielle
d'être le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 d'ailleurs
Bruno Retailleau la précisé nous on a un
problème de calendrier et un problème de
modalité de désignation mais pas de
personnes pour vous ça peut être que lui
que lui le jeu le jeu resto vous savez
il peut dans la vie politique en deux
ans en trois ans en 4 ans il peut se
passer des choses qui misaient sur
Emmanuel Macron en 2013 je pense que
personne n'aurait mis un billet
excusez-moi l'expression sur le
président de la République actuelle donc
attends attention et réfléchissons
ensemble puis vous savez une campagne
interne moi je me méfie de faire des
campagnes internes sous forme de prêtres
non pas Bruno Retailleau il fait sa
campagne sur son nom n'a pas besoin
d'une incantation de Laurent Wauquiez
pour essayer de
traitement de Laurent
j'ai pas dit ça je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention si le seul argument
de campagne d'Éric Ciotti c'est dire on
aura Laurent Wauquiez comme candidat à
l'élection présidentielle je pense que
c'est un peu court par rapport notamment
à des problématiques d'organisation de
partie ou de logiciels idéologiques
sur l'organisation du parti et surtout
sur la ligne du parti parce
qu'évidemment c'est important est-ce que
vous redoutez que
erikiotti se tourne vers l'extrême
droite je pense qu'il a toujours été
très clair là-dessus je vais pas lui
faire un procès il y a effectivement un
cordon sanitaire les deux candidats
veulent retrouver un espace politique
vous savez qu'il y aura une deux toute
façon quand on analyse bien dans les
dans les mois à venir dans les années à
venir une recomposition du paysage
politique puisque la macronie
Renaissance
Emmanuel Macron ne pouvant pas se
représenter
on voit très bien qu'il y a des écuries
qui sont présidentielles qui sont en
train de se préparer dans la macronie
donc il va y avoir une fracturation de
la macronie à nous de retrouver notre
espace politique pour faire revenir les
votants les Français qui se sont égarés
soit chez Emmanuel Macron choix soit
pardon à l'extrême droite afin de
retrouver en fait une famille politique
et un courant de pensée majoritaire dans
le pays mais vous pensez
que l'unité de votre partie vous n'avez
pas d'inquiétude là-dessus
le garant de l'unité du rassemblement
forcer de constater c'est brunes
Retailleau moi je l'ai vu pendant
plusieurs mois dans le cadre du congrès
2021 où on avait 4 sensibilités 5
sensibilités
au Sénat qui se discutait un peu la
première place quand à la primaire de
2027 il a su garder la cohérence du
groupe
aboutir à des textes
satisfaisants avec force et conviction
et cela c'est un très bel exercice qui
l'a préparait justement à la présidence
de notre famille politique effectivement
c'est la meilleure personne je pense
qu'hérit que cioti est très conscient du
fait que l'unité et le rassemblement
c'est le mot d'ordre avant toute chose
pour la pérennisation de notre famille
politique et la survie et la survie
écoutez pour l'instant n'est pas encore
élu moi j'insiste sur un point ce qui
m'a meurtri notamment en corrière c'est
les attaques en règle sur le Sénat je
vous dis franchement la droite ne pourra
pas se recomposer survivre sans la
majorité sénatoriale je pense qu'il y a
du travail à un travail législatif qui
est fait de qualité
remettre en cause ce travail législatif
sans arrêt c'est quand même un peu un
peu gonflé si je veux dire
on va aller chez vous à Marseille on
retrouve les hautes bonjour Léo merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous présidents et
directeur éditorial de La Marseillaise
et les hauts voulaient revenir justement
sur l'état des républicains dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône
mais oui les républicains étaient une
force dominante dans notre territoire et
le contrôler l'ensemble des grandes
villes et des collectivités c'est
désormais absolument plus le cas le
président de Région a d'ailleurs rejoint
le parti présidentiel dans ces
conditions je vais demander au sénateur
le ruguillier et bien quel avenir pour
les LR dans ce territoire et quels
objectifs de reconquête
alors écoutez ce qui est important à
souligner quand même nous sommes la
quatrième ou cinquième fédération en
termes de militants de France avec plus
de
2800-2900 adhérents ça veut dire quelque
chose ça veut dire que notre courant de
pensée notre famille politique n'est pas
morte il y a un travail de
reconstruction de refondation de notre
fédération de partie à l'échelle locale
nous avons commencé à faire le tour des
des comités de circonscription des 16
comités de circonscription que qui
structure le département des
Bouches-du-Rhône et puis il faut pas
oublier vous l'avez dit on a perdu
Marseille mais on a des maires de
grandes villes qui sont toujours et
l'air qui au quotidien défendent
défendre nos idées mais en oeuvre des
politiques publiques et c'est sur ces
mers c'est sur ces élus locaux que nous
voulons nous nous appuyer pour refonder
refonder la droite à l'échelle des
Bouches-du-Rhône
[Musique]
bon déjà nous ne sommes pas invités ce
soir à l'Élysée
ça nous rassure non mais trêve de
plaisanterie sur ce sujet le Sénat a
toujours pris c'est ses responsabilités
ça fait plus de 4 exercices budgétaires
dans le cadre du PSS que nous proposons
le report de l'âge légal mais au-delà de
ça cette réforme de retraite ne doit pas
se polariser uniquement sur le report de
l'âge légal je m'explique on ne peut pas
demander des efforts supplémentaires aux
Français dans ce domaine là si nous
n'avons pas à leur proposer également de
nouveaux droits c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposerons clairement que
il ne peut pas y avoir de retraite
minimum en dessous de 1200 euros vous
connaissez toutes et tous des petites
retraites notamment d'agriculteurs à
moins de 900 euros parfois 800 euros qui
ont travaillé 47 ans parfois c'est pas
entendre et puis on a fait une
proposition et Bruno Retailleau a fait
cette proposition de dire voilà pour un
un enfant handicapé la personne de
révolution quand les parents
disparaissent doit être pérennisé pour
pour l'enfant mais il faut aussi qu'on
travaille sur la pénibilité
du travail et essayer d'avoir une
barreisation du départ en retraite en
fonction en fonction du métier il est
inconcevable pour moi qu'un maçon qui a
travaillé dur pendant 37 38 39 ans
soit amené à partir en retraite au-delà
de de 62 63 64 ans tout ça ça doit se
discuter et dans le même temps j'ajoute
il faut s'intéresser s'interroger aussi
sur l'alignement des régimes spéciaux et
dernier point si on demande des efforts
aux Français l'État doit produire
également ses propres euphores notamment
dans la fraude sociale parce que je vous
rappelle que la fraude sociale c'est 15
à 45 milliards d'euros par an une
réforme des retraites c'est une économie
de 10 à 15 milliards donc vous voyez il
faut dans tous les domaines accès notre
action pour être crédible aux yeux des
Français merci
à la Une de votre journal merci Léo
d'avoir été avec nous depuis Marseille
on va parler du Sénat parce que dans 10
mois ce challenge des élections
sénatoriales hier le Sénat votait un
texte sur le déroulement de cette
élection vous en étiez le rapporteur
Steve Jourdain nous fait le résumé de
cette séance
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur sénateur bonjour
sera donc renouvelée de moitié hier un
texte était examiné pour modifier les
règles de ce scrutin le texte a été
adopté mais avant d'en parler il faut
nous expliquer comment fonctionne
effectivement commençons par rappeler
que les sénateurs sont élus pour un
mandat de 6 ans et que la chambre haute
est renouvelée par moitié tous les trois
ans alors le vote pour les sénatoriales
ça va être un peu particulier puisqu'on
parle en fait de deux types de scrutins
différents en fonction des départements
concernés dans les départements les
moins peuplés qui désignent un ou deux
sénateurs l'élection se fait au scruter
un majoritaire à deux tours dans les
départements qui désignent trois
sénateurs ou plus on utilise le scrutin
de liste à la représentation
proportionnelle à un seul tour quoi
qu'il en soit le vote a lieu au cours
d'une même journée électorale qu'il
s'agisse d'un scrutin ou à deux tours il
s'ouvre à 8h30 et ce clos à 17h30 Oriane
et justement les sénateurs souhaitent
revenir sur les règles qui entourent
cette horaire de clôture oui parce que
la particularité de ces élections
sénatoriales c'est qu'on vote le même
jour pour le et le second tour dans les
petits départements et qu'entre ces deux
tours et bien il y a pas de temps pour
faire campagne pourquoi et bien parce
qu'en vertu une loi votée en 2019 il est
interdit de diffuser de la propagande
électorale à partir de la veille du
scrutin il y a aussi interdiction de
diffuser les résultats en métropole
avant la fermeture du dernier bureau de
vote en pratique ça pose problème parce
que les résultats du premier tour sont
officiellement proclamés en fin de
matinée parfois même affiché sur les
bureaux de vote mais la presse a
interdiction des divulguer et les
candidats ne peuvent pas mener une
véritable campagne d'entre de torian
tout ça va changer et oui c'est le sens
de la proposition de loi adopter hier
par le Sénat selon le texte proposé par
le sénateur François Noël buffet les
candidats pourront désormais faire
campagne entre les deux tours du scrutin
l'embargo sur les résultats imposés
jusqu'à 17h30 à également été supprimé
ce qui veut dire que les résultats du
premier tour pourront être diffusés en
fin de matinée bonne nouvelle pour les
journalistes bonne nouvelle pour les
électeurs et vive le consensus Sénat
gouvernement écoutez
je crois profondément au dialogue à la
possibilité de s'accorder sur les
meilleurs compromis et à la nécessité de
dégager des consensus je pense que cette
proposition de loi qui nous a été
présentée votée à l'unanimité en
commission comme je le disais nous en
offre d'ores et déjà une bonne occasion
elle porte bien sûr sur un sujet
sensible car touchant à la mécanique
même de notre démocratie mais elle se
fonde aussi sur un constat que nous
partageons tous celui du caractère
inadéquat des modifications de 2019 le
texte a donc été adopté monsieur le
sénateur le texte va maintenant aller à
l'Assemblée nationale vous savez quand
est-ce qu'il va être inscrit à l'ordre
du jour on a demandé au gouvernement
d'aller très vite en la matière puisque
vous savez que derrière il y a des
guides notamment pour pour les grands
électeurs et pour les candidats à ces
élections sénatoriales à publier il faut
faire beaucoup de pédagogie parce que
vous l'avez brillamment
rappelé effectivement il y aura une
modification des règles notamment la
propagande entre les deux tours il faut
rappeler également que nous n'avons pas
le droit de faire campagne entre le
samedi 0h et le dimanche après la
réouverture à 11h30 du premier entre le
premier et le second tour donc ça
demande beaucoup de pédagogie et ce
qu'il faut également souligner c'est que
ces dépenses électorales puisque comme
il y aura une ouverture de la campagne
électorale en transh30 et 15h30 ces
dépenses électrobles effectivement
pourrait être éligible dans les petits
départements dans les 51
circonscriptions jusqu'à 51 départements
qui sont concernés par ce mode de
scrutin et bien ces dépenses électorales
ça sera toujours à la Commission
nationale des comptes de campagne de
savoir si elles sont recevables ou non
pour
déjeuner avec des électorales
sénatoriaux mais derrière la campagne
aussi la diffusion de tracts en fait ou
des appels téléphoniques ou autres donc
il y a pas que ce polarisé sur le sur
les festins sénatoriaux soi-disant entre
le premier second tour mais en plus
cette proposition loi sera adoptée avant
la prochaine élection avant septembre
prochain l'objectif c'est qu'elle soit
mise en application avant septembre 2023
et pour qu'elle soit mis en application
il faut très vite janvier février dans
le calendrier parlementaire que
l'Assemblée nationale puisse voter à
l'identique bien évidemment le texte
mais vous avez vu ça fait l'unanimité
de des différents groupes politiques je
pense pas que l'assemblée revienne sur
sur cet unanimité juste très très
rapidement ça veut dire que pour ces
élections on aura une diffusion
progressive des résultats tout au fil de
la journée non mais le fil de l'eau
était essentiel parce que ce qu'il
fallait aussi je pense corriger c'est
que certains médias locaux ou les
réseaux sociaux ou Internet diffusés au
fil de l'eau ces résultats alors que des
médias nationaux comme comme votre
chaîne qui était quand même la première
concernée ne pouvait pas et c'est une
certaine forme de frustration également
et pour une bonne informations également
des Français des grandes électeurs
c'était important de diffuser ça au fil
de l'eau on s'est interrogé sur le fait
que est-ce potentiellement sa
modifierait la sincérité du scrutin dans
les départements limitrophes on a
considéré que l'élection sénatoriale
c'est quand même avant tout une élection
locale merci Steve merci beaucoup et
merci et
à tous du Congrès elle a l'air tout
à fait merci d'avoir été avec nous dans
20 minutes dans le club des territoires
on parlera du Congrès on parle aussi des
coupures d'électricité puisque l'annonce
d'un plan gouvernemental a provoqué
l'inquiétude hier Emmanuel Macron a
fustigé les scénarios de la peur on y
reviendra merci Stéphane de rugby
d'avoir été avec nous c'est une autre
idée alors qui nous rejoint à Florence
Portelli